when is a coed shower scene not just a
coed shower scene starship troopers is
way more than just casual nudity fascist
formal wear and giant alien bugs this
sci-fi satire was light years ahead of
its time
starship troopers goes to work right
away shaping its viewers brains into the
ideal mindset for a soldier the opening
scenes feature commercials from a 23rd
century regime known as the united
citizen federation
the clips vary from information on the
savagery of the arachnid enemy to
positive outcomes for enlisting in the
military the not so subtle brainwashing
leaves you confused about your feelings
towards starship troopers and that's
helped this cult classic shine brighter
over the years the military propaganda
videos are truly a unique form of satire
one that becomes more transparent with
each viewing director paul verhoeven
claimed to have only read a couple
chapters of the source material robert
highline's 1959 novel before retiring it
to the dust bed in an interview with
empire he explained
it's a very right wing book and with the
movie we tried and i think at least
partially succeeded in commenting on
that at the same time all the way
through we were fighting with the
fascism the ultra militarism
rather than glorify the book's fascist
elements beerhoven pulled us into the
muck with an awareness of something
being terribly wrong with this
totalitarian society and its military
obsession its satirical attributes are
constructed so well that it's easy to
miss the film's intentions as it
presents a developed form of fascism on
a cosmic scale these details even sailed
right over the heads of many critics who
accused verhoeven of being a neo-nazi
himself they completely misunderstood
his achievement in taking fascist
rhetoric and dressing it up in satire as
a warning
the opening segment of starship troopers
teases us with news footage of the
battlefield our primary protagonist
johnny rico is delivered a major blow
from his adversaries before the intro
sequence fades out to a more peaceful
time before all the mayhem on the bugs
planet clindotu when we do return to the
same scene later on we get a different
view of this same battle through the
eyes of the soldiers complete with shots
of the cameraman who captured the
carnage in the propaganda video we saw
earlier while troops are unloading
magazines at their enemy the man holding
the studio camera remains in the thick
of it documenting the bloodshed with a
steady hand there are numerous ways to
die for the cause and the news cameraman
goes out in a barrage of cinematic glory
in the starship troopers universe earth
in the 23rd century looks to be a lavish
time to be alive complete with sleek
technology and bright shiny lights the
central plot follows rico closely while
he reaches his decision to enlist in the
military along with his girlfriend
carmen and his best friend carl from
this narrative viewpoint the people of
earth look like they live a cozy life in
reality we're seeing the lifestyle of
someone in a much higher tax bracket the
tax plans in this world aren't explained
to us but noticing the little details
makes it clear that rico's parents are
left with plenty of scratch
rico's home is a spacious house with
towering crystal clear windows perched
atop a mountainside the future looks
wonderful from the viewpoint of the
wealthy also lending credence to rico's
financial upbringing is his father's
counter-argument for enlisting rather
than doing his part for society rico's
dad would rather him go on vacation with
the family before beginning his first
semester at harvard neither of which are
available to those from meager means
starship troopers does such a fantastic
job of world building that you won't
even recognize it's happening in the
same way that new recruits are
brainwashed into operating the cogs of
war we're subjected to the same devices
to help us realize the sordid reality of
this future the propaganda commercials
aren't presented as though the
characters are watching them at the
moment but as if the filmmakers are
recruiting us to learn more about the
world they created
and laced throughout the informative
commercials are details about the
vastness of this universe when we aren't
getting battle advice we are presented
with interplanetary diagrams and earth
politics the commercials have a slightly
humorous characteristic to them but
don't let that distract you from seeing
the bigger picture the small details in
each quick segment expands on the world
of starship troopers it's through these
moments that we learn about the location
of the bug planet foreshadowing about
smart bugs earth's war council decisions
and more it's here we get to see the
fascist bureaucracy in action and we see
a world where the media is controlled by
the state we know creating a mental
block when seeing commercials is
instinctual for most denizens of the
21st century but we recommend paying
attention to these ones
as it stands today we are approaching an
earth population of 8 billion souls the
exponential growth will likely lead to
gigantic numbers by the time we hit the
23rd century on a planet led by a
reactionary military government like in
starship troopers you'd think officials
would enact a type of control for
population growth turns out there is one
succinct chunk of dialogue that informs
us of the bureaucratic path towards
parenthood in this future it's buried in
a scene that every single viewer
remembers and not for its informative
dialogue the communal shower scene in
starship troopers has so much casual
nudity that it distracts from all the
expository dialogue that serves to
expand the world one of the soldiers
begins asking his squad mates their
reason for enlisting in the military
among the answers are career ambitions
college funding and civic duty however
there's one especially interesting
answer from a female soldier and it
involves a desire to have children that
tells us that not only do you have to
register for a license in order to have
kids but it's also not a sure thing and
requires proving yourself to society
it's something to think about while
sitting in bumper-to-bumper traffic
rico has delivered a tough blow when he
loses a soldier while leading his squad
through a training exercise we could
argue about how the man's helmet
wouldn't have done much to protect him
from a bullet to the face but that's of
little consequence
it's what happens after rico signs his
letter of resignation that's interesting
after the incident his parents call him
and he informs them he's coming home the
call ends with daylight slowly being
snuffed out over his mom and dad before
the signal goes dead the reasoning
behind the signal loss is explained so
quickly that you might miss it it comes
so fast because evidently news stations
have a magical ability to assemble a
compelling news package instantaneously
as soon as rico grabs his bag to leave
after his phone call troops begin
rushing to the command center to take in
the news of a bug meteor that's
decimated rico's hometown of buenos
aires the time between the phone call
with his parents and the news being
reported is less than a minute not only
that but in this span of time the war
council has gathered and decided earth
is officially going to war with the
arachnids of clindothu in a population
obsessed with military might political
bureaucracy moves much quicker when war
is involved the reaction to the meteor
strike on buenos aires happens so fast
that you have to wonder if the
government knew it was coming and saw it
as a desirable outcome there's no better
way to whip your population into a
frenzy and march them into battle in the
united citizen federation becoming a
citizen is paramount citizenship comes
with a highly sought after level of
respect in this society it opens
pathways financially in the same way
that it does in current times but the
future residents of earth view it as the
only respectable way to become a
contributing member of society the most
definitive statement in regards to
attaining value in this world comes from
the funeral for dizzy when rico is
giving his eulogy the heartfelt speech
is filled with emotion and it's also a
declaration on what's required to garner
respect it isn't enough to be a good
friend being a soldier is admirable but
it's more about the path it creates a
path towards the ultimate goal of
upgrading from simply being a civilian
to being a citizen in the federation
individuality is of little importance
and your life is only given value when
offered up as a sacrificial lamb for the
cause
anyone with basic understanding of human
anatomy will probably have trouble
accepting the brain bug's ability to
absorb our knowledge by sucking our gray
matter out but it's a little easier to
accept this detail when you remember the
presence of psychics and starship
troopers this ability isn't featured
heavily and it's only talked about in
scenes with neil patrick harris's
character carl in an earlier scene it
looks like he's trying to test rico's
psychic abilities with a playing card
prediction game but it's actually about
carl flexing his own mental aptitude
during the psychic test carl is trying
to send a telepathic message to rico
giving him the answer as to what card is
being displayed you can tell as much by
carl's mannerisms during the test the
failed use of his skill plays a part in
showing us character growth in the later
half of starship troopers after he
rescues carmen rico posits that it was
carl who mentally projected her location
to him carl slyly rejects the claim but
his smirk reveals the truth about that
statement if the uniforms and symbols
featured on the united citizen
federation's attire look suspiciously
third reich it's because they are the
filmmakers recognized the original
starship troopers novel as having an
intriguing sci-fi story but they also
acknowledged the book contained a hearty
dose of totalitarian rhetoric paul
verhoeven aimed to have that
characteristic shine through
sarcastically in the form of satire the
nazi symbolism was meant to help you
realize that these characters may be
heroes but they're heroes in a fascist
society by the end of the film the
propaganda commercials have done a
sufficient job of putting us into the
mindset of people living on earth in the
23rd century in order to pull back on
the reigns verhoeven tried to make the
nods to nazi germany obvious he stated
in an interview with the guardian the
soldiers were like something out of nazi
propaganda i even put one in an ss
uniform but no one noticed i thought
neil patrick harris arriving on the set
in an ss uniform might clear it up the
small detail didn't stop some critics
from warping the director's vision
instead viewing starship troopers as a
twisted nod to the third reich
verhoeven's motives may have been
misunderstood when the movie was
released but we see the underlying
intentions now and we're still unsure
about whether or not we should laugh
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one